ladies and gentlemen today we are
uncovering quite possibly the largest
giveaway scam in history and the crazy
thing
is that it's still going on right now as
we speak
guys i am talking of course about
instagrammer
jay mazzini now i'll introduce you to
this guy
i'll give you everything so first let me
say he's uh he's very requested
and i actually put together something
for you guys let's watch
there this is the side that jay mazzini
wants you to see
he has a bunch of posts on his instagram
everywhere
where he's giving away money and he
wants to be seen like that he wants to
be seen like sort of like a mr beast 2.0
mr
altruism he's constantly giving away
money but the question is
where did he get this money to be giving
away to everyone
well he'll tell you he owns an academy
where he teaches
trading and he also owns a clothing
company called
mazzini italy i got a clothing line
i got an academy we sell clothes
we teach stocks now according to him the
clothing company alone is worth
8 million dollars pretty impressive for
an influencer
who has one million followers most
people on instagram who have one million
followers
are making a decent living but they're
not making anywhere near eight million
dollars
eight million dollars not worth this is
what the companies estimated
at but when you start digging deeper we
find out why
jay mazzini is getting so many orders on
his site this is going to be a mystery
box
minimum order of three mazzini products
in order to win what
in order to win maybe ten thousand
dollars
maybe twenty thousand maybe thirty
thousand see this
is how jay mazzini really makes his
money
he does giveaways where he will say for
the next
x number of orders i'll be giving you
back
money and it's not like an insignificant
amount this is often
life-changing amounts of money but the
requirement
is you have to buy products from his
site mazzinitaly.com
in order to enter to win now on the
ftc's own website they say the signs of
a prize scam
is that number one you have to pay
legitimate sweepstakes
don't make you pay a fee or buy
something this is in contrast to what
jay mazzini does he forces you to buy
his products oftentimes he says you know
oh you have to buy
five items seven items ten items from my
site but he keeps saying
you're gonna win a ton of money and guys
it's it's a lot so here's just a few of
them for the next thousand orders
i'll be placing in twelve thousand
dollars in each order
twelve thousand dollars okay twelve
thousand dollars pay attention minimum
order six mazzini italy products
this is another one for the next 300
mazzini italy orders
i'll be placing in forty thousand
dollars in each order
okay think about that for 300 orders
he's gonna place forty thousand dollars
in each one
and i know most of you guys already
smell a gigantic scam
right obviously but he insists it's real
guys it's real and
let's do the math here okay i went and i
checked
what's the most jay mazzini could be
making off of this little
little thing right let's say you buy the
most expensive thing
on his site well according to his own
slider in the all
items section most expensive product is
85
so you're paying 85 and minimum order is
minimum order is non mizzini italy
products
so the max you can make per person is
765 dollars and this guy is saying
he's gonna give away forty thousand
dollars to each of those people
meaning he's running at a net loss of 39
000 per customer that's what he's saying
that's the math what comes next then
should come as literally a surprise to
no one
people start coming out of the word work
saying that they were told by jay
mazzini that they won
and then they never got money i was
alive with jay mazzini
he told me i want two thousand dollars i
have screen recorded and everything
now i am opening this up i supposedly
won
i was alive and i still didn't win of
course nothing's in the bags guys
i mean this should not come as a
surprise to anyone you literally cannot
do this giveaway it's impossible
so what does this mean it means that if
jamizini's telling the truth and his
clothing line's worth eight million
dollars
he basically created that from nothing
by telling people he's gonna give away
all this money by lying to them and how
does he do it remember
again it all goes back to the beginning
this image that he's cultivating
isn't on accident he wants to be known
as the guy who gives away money right
this is what he wants to be seen doing i
just wanted to give you this for you
this is all a facade though literally
he's doing this
so that you believe him when he says
i'll give you forty thousand dollars
i'll give you twelve thousand dollars
i'll give you ten thousand dollars
but it's not true and ladies and
gentlemen there's been an undercurrent
of dissatisfied customers
that have swept through to the point
where he's getting banned from various
payment platforms like he even got
banned from paypal
he no longer can use paypal which is why
he uses zelle now
but in his instagram story he's seen
trying to buy a fresh paypal because he
got banned
look who has a paypal they want to sell
a business paypal with a good reputation
in history basically he needs a business
paypal so he wants to buy one
because he got banned from his current
one because the chargebacks and the
refunds that people are going through
are insane but this is just further
evidence of
the scam it's falling apart this is to
the point where he's even had to address
and make up excuses for why people
aren't getting their money
so one of the things he's set out to do
now is that the money which he's
supposedly
sending in the mail he says he puts
forty thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars
into packages physical packages she
ships out to people
he says that the post office is stealing
from them postal workers are destroying
boxes and taking the prizes
and then they blame jay for not getting
the prize
so he's saying it's not my fault you
didn't get paid hey
ups stole my stole your money and guys
that's not the only time he's addressed
it see
jay mazzini also went on bars on i-95
and addressed it there as well i went
through a lot of
accusations i've done a lot for the
community i know some people are selfish
they won't even do enough
they won't even do nothing for anybody
all right guys quit being selfish give
away
40 000 to the next 300 people like jay
mazzini
by the way that's a giveaway of 12
million dollars keep in mind that this
clown says his whole company
is worth 8 million although he doesn't
have the cash in one giveaway he
promised
12 million but yeah he's a guy who does
stuff for the community
as opposed to selfish people i don't see
bill gates doing nothing for the
community
i'm not even gonna get into this one
bill gates has been taking a little heat
online lately but to say
that bill gates doesn't do anything for
the community while you do
yeah uh this guy's clueless maybe
because bill gates isn't going on
instagram live bragging every time he
gives away money maybe that's why you
don't see him as doing anything for the
community i don't know
bro i'll tell you one thing bro there's
a lot of people
when i launch my brand i do giveaways
this gets into his biggest excuse and
the biggest
load of garbage you will ever hear in
your life okay this is how he reconciles
not paying people money and a lot of
people lost at the end of the day you're
getting the product
let's hear that again a lot of people
want a lot of people lost at the end of
the day you're getting the product
one more time at the end of the day
you're getting a product so what i
didn't pay you forty thousand dollars
you bought the clothes because you just
wanted the clothes no
they bought your products because they
wanted the money
it's not at the end of the day if you
didn't win you got a product
no you're robbing people because the
only reason they're going in and buying
your crappy clothes
is because they want money it's not
because they're in love with the mazzini
brand
he says this all the time by the way
this is his big excuse he goes on entire
rants about how he doesn't owe you
anything
damn how scamming how
i got a clothing line i got an academy
we sell clothes we treat stocks
you call the brand the scam why because
i can't give everybody money
instead of looking for something go get
up and work this is his big thing
oh i'm about people working no you're
running a giveaway scam
here's the incredible thing about this
live by the way and you can't make this
stuff up
after going on this rant about how he
needs people to become self-sufficient
what does he do so listen starting now
since i'm faithful starting now
for the next hundred people to enroll in
the messini academy
be giving away thirty thousand dollars
to each person
let's rewind that again guys for the
next hundred people to enroll in the
mizzini academy
let's pull out the calculator i'll be
giving away thirty thousand dollars to
each person
how do you so right during a speech
where he's saying
you need to work blah blah blah and stop
asking me for money
he promises you three million dollars in
a giveaway
so that's who jay mazzini is in a
nutshell he's doing what is in my
opinion the largest giveaway scam
and we're going to tally up how much
he's promised at the end of this video
but i want to show you how often he does
this because
unfortunately even though repetition is
repetitive
it also proves a point so let's walk
through some of his giveaways okay and
then at the end of this video i'm gonna
show you how much
total he's promised versus how much he
could have made if every single person
bought the most expensive item on his
entire website
okay for the next thousand orders
i'll be placing in twelve thousand
dollars in each order
minimum order six mazzini italy products
okay so he just promised to wait 12
million dollars
and the total sales he would have reaped
from that if everyone bought a minimum
order of six
and they paid the maximum amount per
item eighty-five dollars he would have
made sales
of five hundred and ten thousand dollars
but he promised twelve million
okay let's go on this is another one for
the next three hundred mazzini italy
orders
i'll be placing in forty thousand
dollars in each order
minimum order is non mazzini italy
products it can't only be masked
okay same deal he's trying to give away
12
million dollars here as well just in
different amounts 300 orders
but he's giving away forty thousand
dollars this time minimum order of nine
meaning he can make 229 thousand dollars
and again that's sales not profit this
only applies for the next
800 people to send the 750
listen you win you win you lose you lose
at the end of the day
you're automatically getting the ebook
yeah again the same thing well you're
getting a product even if you lose
no dude people aren't buying a minimum
order of three
mazzini ebooks in order to get
themselves smarter
you got to purchase a minimum order of
three mazzini
academy ebooks like why would someone
buy three copies of a book that's your
requirement of his sweepstakes
there's so much fraud here it's insane
and the fact that it's still going on
is still mind-blowing to me this man has
a million followers or close to a
million followers on instagram
and he's running a scam of this caliber
and where's the ftc on this
for the next 5 000 people to subscribe
to the mazzini academy
i'll be selecting 200 winners giving
them
ten thousand dollars each okay another
two million dollar giveaway
casual oh boy this is one of my
favorites right here guys
here we go for each person to place in
one
a thousand dollar mazzini italy order
it's a lot but i'll be cutting out
a check for a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars
you spend a thousand dollars on his
website i'll pay you a hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars for
shopping thanks for shopping
dude what is bill gates done for the
community recently guys
for the next 800 people to place in the
order in the mazzini italy site
they'll be forty thousand dollars
in um on each order minimum order
guys that's 32 million dollars he just
promised away
on a live stream on instagram either
this man is gandhi either he's a rich
billionaire son who wants to burn
through the money
as fast as humanly possible or he's
defrauding customers
you decide what you want to believe so i
think that's enough evidence to sort of
prove my point
but i calculated out you know how much
money total he's promised and it's
a hundred million dollars he's probably
over a hundred million dollars
and the maximum he could have made from
those 100 million dollars
is seven million dollars in sales
coincidentally
uh pretty close to what he says his
company is worth
eight million dollars net worth i'm not
saying like i said before i don't have a
million cash but
my network i do like what he's doing
right now
is illegal i mean i'm going to tell you
right now you can't promise to give away
money
in exchange for payment right in
exchange for buying a product
and then not give away the giveaway and
it leads me to something else
i kind of want to talk about which is
this sort of uh
fake altruism that's been going around
recently
and uh i just want to go out on a limb
here i mean i know i'm gonna sound
like i'm entering conspiracy land crazy
world y'all are gonna say stephen you've
gone off the deep end
but i want to humbly submit to you guys
that these people
may not be that good i'm not saying
they're necessarily bad but you have to
watch these people with the dose of
skepticism maybe
they're not just doing it out of the
kindness of their heart if every time
they give away money they have to film
it
there's nothing wrong with you know
saying that you're giving away money in
order to raise awareness about an issue
right like if you're raising money for
cancer
but at the same time if every time they
do it they have to get the camera crew
they have to say
oh they have to say how much money
they're giving this is eight thousand
dollars you know
i'm giving it to a poor person look how
cool i am i don't know
if that's your whole brand i'm
suspicious so yeah that covers it i mean
i really wanted to go in depth with this
one i think we have
i think we've definitively showed the
scam
as it is uh you guys can't be doing
these instagram giveaways thinking
you're gonna get away with it
people are gonna catch on they are gonna
start cataloging it
and eventually he will be caught ladies
and gentlemen thanks for coming by
thanks for watching
spreadsheet in the link below if you
want to go see the evidence for yourself
and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
uh